faite de ruptures sur les mesures
arrivait à échéance
à hauteur de 15 millions d'euros au delà
de cet objectif de continuité 50
nouvelles bagarres pour être pourront
être autorisés en 2014 concernant l'aide
à l'investissement
indispensable un secteur caractérisé par
des besoins importants
de remise à niveau des boîtes et des
bâtis on nous souhaitons également
souligné que l'eau j'étais l'agrégat
composé de l'ondam et du produit la csa
intègre enfin l'affectation de 2% de la
csa au financement du pays du plan
d'investissement qui permet d'améliorer
les établissements
très bien merci madame la ministre
madame bertinotti
merci beaucoup je pense que leur idole
touraine du déjà exprimé quel était le
sens de de ce budget en matière de
politique familiale je veux juste
repréciser que nous avions eu l'occasion
et le premier ministre l'avait fait au
début du mois de juin d'expliquer
justement le sens de cette politique
familiale qui est à la fois qui traduit
à la fois la volonté de pérenniser la
branche famille et en même temps aussi
de parvenir à ce qu' on puisse continuer
à développer les services aux familles
avec une politique très volontariste
des du développement des places
d'accueil des 0 3 ans puisque vous savez
que c'est à hauteur de 275 mille places
sur sur cinq ans avec aussi des efforts
très substantiel fait sur le soutien à
la parentalité
quand on regarde les on est obligé de
devoir à la fois des mesures qui
relèvent du plf et des mesures qui
relèvent du plfss mais qui vont toutes
dans le même sens une volonté de
davantage de solidarité et de
prestations mais mieux ciblées en faveur
des familles modestes
c'est le cas pour l'allocation de
soutien familial qui est revalorisé qui
concerne directement les familles
monoparentales dont on sait que parmi
elles il y a un taux de précarité et de
pauvreté plus fort que la moyenne
nationale et la revalorisation du
complément familial qui lui touche les
familles avec trois enfants
et plus je voudrais je ne peux pas faire
l'économie de même si cela n'est pas
dans le plfss de deux d'évoquer
effectivement ce qui a été la baisse du
plafond du quotient familial
pour juste repréciser je le dis d'autant
plus volontiers que ce cette baisse ne
concerne que 12% des familles les plus
aisées
ce qui veut dire que 88 % des familles
ne sont pas concernés par cette mesure
et que
pour donner un
éclairage encore plus précis commence à
être concernés si l'on prend le cas de
famille avec deux enfants des couples
dont le niveau de ressources est au
minimum de 5600 euros par mois
donc voilà pour repréciser que c'est
aussi au travers de cette volonté de
pérennisation de la branche famille mais
aussi cette volonté de pouvoir
continuer à intensifier les efforts des
services des services rendus aux
familles que ce soit en matière
d'accueil petite enfance ou en matière
de soutien à la parentalité
très bien merci mesdames les ministres
je vais donc donner la parole dans un
premier temps à nos rapporteur donc yves
daudigny rapporteur général your ensuite
isabelle pasquet pour la branche famille
et georges labazée
il souhaitait intervenir son médico
social il veut de 10 me merci madame la
présidente mais aussi madame les
ministres des exposés nous venons
d'entendre alors que ce soit clair c'est
une évidence mon soutien vous êtes
acquis sans réserve dans la démarche que
vous avez exposé les lysiens va les unes
et les autres pour la présentation de ce
téléviseur si vous le permettez quelques
observations et en même temps questions
qui peuvent permettre si possible des
éclairages complémentaires
une observation générale depuis 2010
l'évolution des dépenses de santé en
général et celle d'assurance maladie en
particulier dans cette évolution est en
rupture par rapport aux 50 dernières
années puisqu'elle progresse à un rythme
inférieur à 3% par an et malgré cela le
déficit de la branche maladie reste à un
niveau élevé le caractère donc durable
de la maîtrise de l'ondam que vous avez
mis en avant madame la ministre on revêt
donc une grande sensibilité
éclairage possible qu'elles sont madame
la ministre ces facteurs explicatifs de
la sous-consommation des dépenses
d'assurance maladie sur les derniers
exercices
et surtout comment pouvons nous réunir
les conditions d'un maintien donc de
l'ondam à un taux de progression de 2 4%
deuxième point le plfss pour 2014
contient un nombre important de mesures
relatives à l'assurance maladie il
engage plusieurs éléments vous l'avez
également souligné de la stratégie
nationale de santé notamment la
réorientation notre système vers les
soins primaires
limitée par le champ défini dans la loi
organique il s'insère dans une réforme
d'ensemble qui devra nécessairement être
parachevé dans une future loi de santé
publique que vous avez annoncé et que
nous espérons tous donc pour 2014 alors
il reprend en jeu il est agréable pour
moi de l'évoquer plusieurs propositions
que notre commission a fait et je cite
par exemple un amendement que j'avais
déposé que j'ai déposée l'an passé sur
les médicaments biologiques
similaire mais je pense surtout à la
réforme de la t2a
en accord avec les conclusions du
rapport que nous avons adoptée l'année
dernière le plfss permettra de prendre
en compte la spécificité des
établissements situés dans des zones
isolées ou peu denses et de lutter
contre l'effet potentiellement
inflationniste de ce mode de financement
je voulais vraiment mettre ceci en avant
toujours en ce qui concerne l'hôpital à
une question le plfss prévoit un nouveau
report dont de 2016 2018 de la mise en
oeuvre de la facturation individuelle
alors que cette évolution peut paraître
indispensable si nous voulons avancer
sur la question du parcours de santé ou
des parcours de santé que nous appelons
tous tout je pense de nous veut alors
sans facturation clairement identifiés
par patient est il néanmoins possible
d'imaginer des parcours financé de
manière transversale en amont et en aval
de l hôpital
autre sujet dans le prolongement des
objectifs fixés par le président de la
république plusieurs mesures du plfss
concerne la couverture santé
complémentaire au moins au niveau de
deux articles l'article 4 prévoit
notamment les modalités de participation
des eaux calmes ou forfait minimes et
sahin traitant pour un montant de 150
millions d'euros par an comme prévue
dans l'avenant numéro 8 donc
l'interrogation existent sur le schéma
retenu dans la rédaction actuelle du
plfss et ce qui n'aurait pas été
possible de prévoir d'autres modalités
de financement de son côté l'article 45
engage une notamment une réforme de la
qualité des contrats des complémentaires
santé en définissant mieux les contrats
que peuvent bénéficier donc de l'aide
complémentaire santé ainsi que les
contrats solidaires et responsables
cette réforme ne va-t-elle pas de pair
avec une différenciation plus sensible
entre les taux de thc à qui s'applique
aux contrats et enfin dernière question
sur un sujet que j'aime bien évoqué l'an
passé déjà vous aviez évoquer une remise
à plat du dossier médical personnalisé
dossier médical personnel pardon
dispositif que la cour des comptes dans
sa forme actuelle a jugé très sévèrement
vous avez récemment évoqué un dossier
médical personnel de deuxième génération
parce qu'éventuellement vous pouvez nous
éclairer sur ce sujet
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
isabelle pasquet rapporteur la branche
famille
merci madame la présidente mais mesdames
les ministres notamment la ministre une
remarque pour commencer je regrette
une nouvelle fois avec la baisse des
cotisations patronales famille destinée
à compenser la hausse des cotisations
patronales retraite la branche famille
fasse office de variable d'ajustement
alors que sa structure de financement
n'a cessé d'être fragilisée ces
dernières années qu'ils puisaient ce
sont les ménages qui via la réforme du
quotient familial vont compenser
eux-mêmes in fine et la branche à la
branche famille cette perte de recettes
première question vous annoncez une
politique volontariste mais tout de même
le plfss pour 2014 prévoit 500 millions
d'euros d'économies de gestion pour
l'ensemble des caisses
de location familiale
à quelle hauteur les caps des caisses de
sécurité sociale la quelle hauteur les
cas vous serez amené à participer à
cette hauteur à cet effort financier et
sachant qu'elles sont déjà fortement
contrainte comment comptez vous
concilier cet objectif avec les
engagements pris dans la nouvelle co
ensuite l'article 56 du plfss instaure
une modulation du montant de
l'allocation de base de la prestation
d'accueil du jeune enfant selon le
niveau de ressources des familles
n'est ce pas là une source de complexité
supplémentaire pour les caf alors que
vous défendez l'idée d'un choc de
simplification administrative
par ailleurs ce même article prévoit le
gel de revalorisation de l'allocation de
base de la paje jusqu'à ce que le
montant du complément familial soit égal
ou supérieur au montant de l'allocation
de base en vigueur au 1er avril 2013 or
le rattrapage entre les deux c'est les
deux prestations ne devrait intervenir
que d'ici 2019 ou 2020 comment justifiez
vous ce choix
ensuite l'article 58 du plfss entend
encadrer les tarifs pratiqués par les
micro crèches en subordonnant le
versement du complément du libre choix
de mode de garde aux familles au respect
d'un micro crèche d'un plafond tarifaire
n'aurait-il pas été possible d'encadrer
directement ses tarifs plutôt que de
passer par le cng
ensuite enfin une dernière question qui
concerne également le cng
lors des débats sur le projet de loi sur
l'égalité hommes femmes je vous avais
posé un certain nombre de questions
concernant le tiers payant pour les
familles les plus modestes
[Musique]
qui faisait appel à une assistante
maternelle
donc la question c'est toujours par
rapport à la complexification des tâches
c'est ce qu'on a évalué la charge de
travail que ça pouvait représenter
et étant donné que ça concerne c' est
destiné surtout à la
retour à l'emploi de des femmes
cela signifie que le recours aux
assistantes maternelles ne se fera pas
de façon régulière c'est à dire
occasionnels donc comment ça va se
passer
pour passer les conventions entre
l'assistante maternelle et et la caf en
c'est vrai que c'est une mesure qui va
bénéficier largement aux familles et
bien sûr aux assistantes maternelles
ceci dit est ce que ça ne va pas
rajouter d une complexification dans les
tâches des caf
merci monsieur georges labazée
rapporteur donc pour la pour la partie
médico social oui merci madame la
présidente je vais adresser aux quatre
questions au ministre présente à je vais
commencer peut-être pas là le plus
proche
quelle est la situation financière
exacte de la sénescence ce qu'on nous
dit que d'asséner sa dispose de beaucoup
d'argent et quand on discute avec des
haches les ars quand il faut obtenir des
financements pour la mise en oeuvre du
médico-social et différents
établissements on nous dit que la csa
n'a pas des moyens à
distribuer je pense pas qu cosepac mais
je pense aussi aux établissements pour
l'accueil des handicapés etc et là nous
sommes vraiment en grande difficulté
puisque le département qui co-décident
avec les ars ont des schémas d'autonomie
ont des schémas
en faveur des personnes âgées des
personnes handicapées et on n'arrive pas
d'émettre en oeuvre faute de crédits qui
descendrait de la c1 et ça alors
derrière cette question
centrale est posé vous en doutez le
problème de la casa alors on a créé dans
la loi de finances et de financement de
la sécurité sociale en 2013
cette contribution
fléchi vers la loi sur la dépendance
elle a été disons
reversé en 2013 entièrement sur le fonds
de solidarité vieillesse et on pouvait
penser que qu'en 2014 toujours dans la
perspective de la loi que l'on flèche de
nouveau ce cette contribution
dite de la casa
un verre le
le futur disons
dispositif concernant
la
l'adaptation
de la société à la halle aux vêtements
dépendance dont la liga nous avons
véritable point d'interrogation parce
qu'on nous dit en même temps oui monde
on ne fait pas la passe et les dernières
ne fait pas cette année puisque la scène
et sa dispose de ressources nécessaires
lors comme brigham à une sorte de
contradiction qui peut paraître un peu
moment au 10 mai la senza des ressources
est nécessaire donc elle pourrait
contribuer au financement du médico
social pour les ars et à me tendre
ce qui est prévu justement pour le
financement de la dépendance
repart vers les fonds de solidarité
vieillesse ça c'était ma première
série de questions la deuxième série
c'est
comme la ministre vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que l'année 2014 vers et disons
le débat sur la loi concernant
l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement nous en sommes qu'ils ont
créés très heureux on souhaite et
qu'elle vienne le plus rapidement
possible mais
pourquoi avez vous décidé de scinder en
deux le texte c'est l'une par la prise
en charge à domicile
et puis de l'autre côté la prise en
charge l'établissement alors que
toutes les analyses et puis notre vie au
quotidien montrent qu'ils conviennent de
fluidifier en permanence ce qui se passe
entre le maintien à domicile
et puis
l'accès dans les établissements maison
de retraite et et autres enfin sur la
troisième question concerne les services
d'aidé et d'accompagnement à domicile je
m'adressais à même de l'onu qui avait
été créé par des finances pour 2012 puis
par la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 est-ce que vous
disposez à l'heure actuelle
d'éléments sur les mesures qui
pourraient être inclus dans le premier
texte que nous examinerons afin de
soutenir durablement le secteur de
l'aide à domicile est une conséquence
ils voulaient de
les tests que me prenne vous avez
annoncé il ya quelques jours et que vous
avez repris tout à l'heure
merci monsieur abbas et mesdames les
ministres je vous laisse répondre alors
je je je vais répondre
qu'est ce qui explique nos limites
d'abord qu'est-ce qui explique la sous
consommation de l'ondam est comment est
ce que on peut arriver à tenir
durablement un an dame
de niveau qui historiquement apparaît
bas et qui paraît nécessaire si nous
voulons sortir de la spirale des
déficits dans laquelle nous nous sommes
trouvé
embarqué dans laquelle nous sommes
trouvé embarqué par défaut de politiques
structurelles je veux quand même insisté
sur ce point parce que on me dit souvent
sur les bancs
de la majeure de l'opposition
d'aujourd'hui on me dit mais c'est la
crise qui expliquent le dérapage ces
dernières moi je veux rappeler que le
déficit de la sécu
ça n'est pas une fatalité la sécurité
sociale a été allégé le budget la
sécurité sociale a été l équilibre
en 2001 jusqu'en 2001
le déséquilibre a commencé à apparaître
en 2002 et surtout il s'est creusé au
tour de 2006 cadre de mes 25,6 à un
moment où nous n'étions pas en période
de crise donc le défi il est bien
d'engager des réformes structurelles qui
nous permettent de réorienter
les dépenses et de mieux répondre aux
défis qui se posent que j'ai évoqué le
vieillissement de la population
l'apparition des maladies chroniques la
nécessité de
réorienter l'activité hospitalière sur
certaines priorités des priorités de
leur activité qui n'est pas du premier
recours et ce sont ces réformes
structurelles et non pas des efforts
demandés aux patients en termes de
déremboursement ou de franchise qui sont
la clé
pourquoi est ce que nous avons sous
consommer la question de la sous
consommation
elle est se trouve que là ça permet de
comment dire d'atteindre d'aller au delà
de l'objectif que nous nous étions fixés
en terme d'économie mais nous ne pouvons
pas considérer que cette sous
consommation est de nature
nécessairement durable un des facteurs
qui expliquent une des raisons qui
explique la sous la sous-consommation de
l'ondam de ville puisque l'eau dame
hospitalier est stable
c'est le moindre recours aux indemnités
journalières
est à l'évidence le moindre recours aux
hôpitaux aux indemnités journalières
est liée aussi à la situation de
l'emploi c'est à dire que quand il ya
moins de
d'actifs quand il ya plus de chômage
moins de gens en activité
il ya moins de gens qui prennent des
indemnités journalières qui ne
travaillent pas ils prennent pas
d'indemnités journalières et on ne peut
pas exclure d'ailleurs que des gens qui
sont en emploi
avec des situations précaires hésitent à
recourir à des indemnités journalières
dans une période d'instabilité du marché
du travail ce pour ce qui est de la
tarification à l'activité je veux
insister sur le point
que nous amorçons un processus
c'est à dire que ce plfss n'est pas la
fin du processus
les travaux se poursuivent dans le cadre
du comité
pour la réforme de la tarification à
l'activité le corps état dans lequel
tous les acteurs concernés sont associés
qui avance bien et c'est ce qui nous a
permis de définir ces trois nouveaux
critères de la tarification
établissement très isolée dégressivité
en cas d'actes important et
parcours de soins autour de
l'expérimentation pour l'insuffisance
rénale chronique
mais le pn nous c'est un processus qui a
vocation à être amplifiées dès l'année
prochaine pour ce qui est de la
facturation individuelle
l'objectif c'est quoi l'objectif c'est
d'une part de meilleures relations entre
les assurés sécurité sociale
d'autre part un rapprochement en forme
de convergence mais de rapprochement
entre l'activité ambulatoire l'activité
de ville et l'activité hospitalière pour
ce qui est de l'activité hospitalière
distinguons deux choses pour ce qui est
des actes et des consultations externes
nous sommes dans les clous et dans les
temps actuellement deux décrets sont en
cours de concertation qui vont permettre
de faire entrer en place progressivement
alors à paris ça viendra un peu après
marseille je connais plus exactement le
calendrier mais qui vont permettre de
faire entrer en
2de
d'appliquer cette facturation
individuelle
en revanche nous avons concrètement
rencontré des difficultés pour ce qui
est des séjours et de la facturation
individuelle des séjours et c'est pour
cela que il y à un report à 2018 très
concrètement nous avons besoin
d'expérimenter des mécanismes des
systèmes d'information qui aujourd'hui
ne nous apporte pas la fiabilité et la
satisfaction
attendus pour ce qui est de la
contribution des complémentaires c'est
un vaste sujet
que je comprends bien
calé sur quels lots quels enjeux lorsque
nous avons eu la négociation sur la
maîtrise des dépassements d'honoraires
les organismes complémentaires se sont
engagés dans a apporté une contribution
de 150 millions d'euros qui doit
permettre de financer des actes
forfaitaire plutôt là y'avait un flou
de médecins qui ne font pas de
dépassements d'honoraires et donc l'idée
c'était que
lle en échange de l'engagement des
médecins à limiter leurs dépassements
d'honoraires qu'il y ait des actes
positifs qu'ils soient posées et en
partie financé par les complémentaires
c'est complémentaire souhaiterait
aujourd'hui que leur participation soit
clairement identifiée par le patient
c'est à dire que quand leur médecin à 5
euros grâce à ses 150 millions d'euros
il y est écrit c'est votre
complémentaire la mutuelle ceci ou
l'assurance là simplement il a été
décidé que ce qui serait
financée par les complémentaires ce sont
des actes forfaitaire
et aujourd'hui ça reviendrait à créer un
acte qui n'auraient aucun financement de
la part de l'assurance maladie et qui
serait entièrement financé même s'il est
très faible en cinq euros pour le
forfait par les complémentaires ce
serait envoyer le signal aux quelques
mois je ne veux pas envoyer parce que ça
n'est pas le sens de ma politique que il
y à des actes dans lesquelles les
assurances complémentaires sont les
seuls payeurs et où il y a non
engagement de l'assurance maladie
obligatoire la contribution des
assurances complémentaires ne peut
intervenir que dans un ensemble un cadre
global dans lequel l'assurance maladie
obligatoire est l'élément central
déterminant est le socle identifiés
comme tels lorsque nous aurons fait le
déploiement du tiers payant généralisé
alors le versement direct par la
complémentaire pourra être réalisée
c'est pour cela qu'après des discussions
et je sais que les organismes
complémentaires auraient souhaité autre
chose mais je le dis dans l'état actuel
des dispositifs tels qu'ils existent
nous avons nous sommes arrivés à l'idée
que cette contribution devait se faire
de manière globale par le biais du plfss
et de façon transitoire dans la tente du
déploiement du tiers payant généralisé
pour ce qui est du dmp j'aurai
l'occasion dans quelques semaines
d'annoncer la deuxième étape cette
deuxième génération
prenons acte de ce que la première g les
rations la première version n'a pas
atteint des résultats souhaités nous
allons nommer je vais nommer un chef de
projet nous allons engager le
déploiement de ce dossier médical dans
le sens souhaité ou identifiés par la
stratégie nationale de santé
c'est-à-dire concentrer le développement
des dossiers médicaux personnalisés sur
les personnes âgées et les personnes
atteintes de maladies chroniques afin
qu'ils aient un intérêt
immédiatement visible à la fois par les
professionnels libéraux et par les
professionnels hospitaliers de la
nécessité de l' échange d'informations 2
2 remarque simplement aux deux questions
je laisserais évidemment dominique
bertinotti et
michèle delaunay répondre aux questions
qui ont été posées sur les branches
concernées
mais je ne peux pas laisser dire que la
branche famille sert de variable
d'ajustement à la politique de la
sécurité sociale dominique bertinotti le
redira mais je ne peux pas laisser dire
cela
surtout après des années où la branche
famille a effectivement servi de
variable d'ajustement où nous avons
d'emblée pris des mesures dès l'année
dernière
pour vale 2012 pour financer apporter
des ressources complémentaires à la
branche famille et il ne s'agit pas de
diminuer les ressources de la branche
famille il s'agit dans le cadre d'une
réflexion sur le financement de la
protection sociale
que je crois vous appelez de vos voeux
par ailleurs mais dans le cadre de cette
réflexion se demander si nous faisons
une différence entre les dépenses qui
sont de nature contributive qui
renvoient à des prestations de nature
contributive et les prestations de
solidarité les prestations de nature
contributive doivent à l'évidence être
financés en lien avec le travail c'est
pour cela que pour nous avons fait le
choix
de la variable cotisations pour le
financement notre politique de retraite
la question est déposée depuis des
années la politique familiale doit-elle
être financée de manière centrale par
des cotisations assises sur le coût du
travail c'est dans le cadre de cette
réflexion que nous avons engagé cette
année une diminution des cotisations
patronales pour la famille qui dont le
et le manque à gagner sera compensée par
le budget de l'état donc il n'ya pas de
variable d'ajustement il y aura une
compensation pour ce qui est de la scnf
ça et
je ferme on connaît parfaitement le
débat
les réserves sont importantes
les réserves de la cns a en 2012
elles sont de 448 millions d'euros
elle était un peu un peu supérieure en
il va y avoir évidemment il ya eu des
décisions prises en 2013
donc à l'arrivée
les les réserves après les décisions qui
vont être prises seront de l'ordre de
230 millions
230 millions à peu près et puis nous
constatons qu'il y à une
sous-exposition en 2013 par rapport aux
projets qui sont engagés qui est de
l'ordre de 130 millions d'euros
ce qui veut dire que des projets peuvent
continuer à se développer
tout en ayant une garantie de
financement
j'insiste là dessus
la loi d'orientation
elle annoncera l'ensemble
des étapes nous allons procéder en deux
étapes mais la loi d'orientation elle
annoncera d'emblée les deux étapes donc
la loi d'orientation elle va dire il ya
une première loi dans laquelle il y a
les différents éléments que j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure et que va compléter
michèle delaunay notamment sur le
domicile et puis il y aura une deuxième
étape qui comportera ceci ceci cela sur
l'hébergement pourquoi pas une seule loi
tout de suite
il faut le dire avec esprit de
responsabilité pour des raisons
financières
plutôt que de faire une loi qui n'est
pas financé ou qui auraient une moindre
ambition pour pouvoir être financés dans
le cadre de la situation actuelle nous
assumons de dire nous mettons en place
un processus qui va monter en puissance
et cette montée en puissance elle se
fait 2015 et puis au delà
mais l'esprit des mesures et le contenu
des mesures sera annoncée dès la loi
d'orientation
merci mesdames touraine mercy nothing
oui
marisol touraine a eu vraiment raison
de dire qu' il est temps il n'est pas
acceptable d'entendre que la branche
famille servent de variable d'ajustement
je tiens à dire que lorsqu'on regarde ce
qu'est la négociation de ce qu'a été la
négociation de la convention d'objectifs
et de gestion avec la cnaf et le niveau
du montant dû finas
les efforts financiers et sont tout à
fait substantiel est très conséquent et
n'ont rien à voir avec les efforts
financiers fait préalablement et je
pense que on ne peut pas laisser dire
que effectivement la branche famille
perdrait des recettes puisque marisol
touraine ni a insisté à la fois sur le
fait que l'intégralité de la baisse de
la cotisation patronale famille sera
compensée par le budget de l'état et que
bien évidemment la branche famille aussi
percevra l'intégralité des gains de la
mesure du quotient familial donc
voilà c'est ensuite effectivement on ne
peut pas s'interdire la réflexion à
venir sur le la nature même et les
fondements même du financement de la
branche famille comme des autres
branches de la sécurité sociale vous
évoquez aussi les 500 millions
d'économies de gestion mais les
économies qui sont demandés à la branche
famille sont déjà inscrites dans la
convention d'objectifs et de gestion et
à ce jour il n'y a aucune demande
d'économies supplémentaires vous avez
aussi abordé des questions après très
très ponctuelle sur la modulation de
l'allocation de base de la paje et le
plafonnement du complément du mode de
garde structure dans les micro crèches
je tiens à dire que en ce qui concerne
la modulation de l'allocation de base de
la paje il s'agit de cibler cette
prestation au bénéfice des familles qui
en ont le plus besoin et que en plus
cette modulation ne va intervenir que
pour des familles dont les enfants sont
vont être à partir du 1er avril 2014 et
pour ces familles à venir il faut savoir
que cette modulation là aussi ne
touchera que 13 % de ces familles à
venir donc là aussi
il faut je dirais prendre conscience que
les trois cas plus des trois quarts ne
sont absolument pas concernés dans cette
modulation du montant de l'allocation de
base de la paje je m'étonne aussi de
votre interrogation sur le plafonnement
du complément de mode de garde structure
dans les micro crèche car je souhaite
vous rappeler que les micro crèches
peuvent être financés par de deux façons
soit par la prestation de service unique
par la ps eut comme les établissements
d'accueil du jeune enfant soit pas
précisément par le complément de mode de
garde structure ce qui est aujourd'hui
pour 63% des micro crèches
le cas est le paradoxe c'est qu'on
vivait dans une situation où il y avait
un plafond relatif à la rémunération des
assistantes maternelles prise en charge
par le complément mode de garde direct
et qu'elle inverse il n'existait aucune
limitation du tarif facturé aux familles
par les micro crèches donc j'ai envie de
dire cette mesure c'est au contraire on
verse le complément mode de garde que si
les microcrèches plafonne leurs tarifs
et que là il ya une mesure de je dirais
de justice face aux modes d'accueil qui
est proposé aux parents et ceux elles
n'ont pas toujours le choix donc
selon qu'elles aient recours à une
assistante maternelle ou dans une crèche
ou une microcrèche effectivement il faut
qu'on arrive à une harmonisation du
reste à charge qui est à supporter par
par les familles quant au tiers payant
sur qui a été proposé dans le cadre de
la loi égalité
femmes hommes bien évidemment que la
cnaf a évalué la charge de travail que
cela pouvait représenter et la cnaf
estime que cette charge de travail est
tout à fait soutenable
ce que demande la cnaf c'est la
réflexion sur un délai de mise en oeuvre
pour précisément effectivement rendre
tout à fait compatibles la mise en
oeuvre de cette réforme où là aussi nous
avons quand même une politique familiale
qui est destiné à aider quand on dit les
familles modestes
c'est tout simplement à permettre à des
familles modestes de pouvoir éduquer
élever leurs enfants dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
je ne dis pas les meilleures conditions
mais dans des conditions tout simplement
satisfaisante en permettant à ces
familles d'avoir accès à un mode de
garde quand on sait que dans les
familles pauvres
95% des enfants n'ont jamais eu des 0 3
ans n'ont jamais accès un seul mode de
garde quel qu'il soit et que c'est un
facteur d'inégalité
considérable y compris dans la la
création et la persistance des futurs
inégalités scolaires donc je pense qu'il
faut apprécier la la volonté de justice
dans l'élaboration et de cette politique
familiale quand
au fond je reviendrai sur effectivement
le propos peu admissible de la variable
d'ajustement mais même sur les effectifs
je tiens à le dire que dans le contexte
budgétaire qui est le nôtre d'avoir
maintenu les effectifs pendant deux ans
de d'autoriser le remplacement par du
personnel qualifié des départs à la
retraite d'avoir provoqué une embauche
de 500 à 700 emplois d'avenir témoigne
de la prise en compte de ce qu'est la
réalité du travail des employés des caf
qui est tout à fait effectivement
fondamental pour le maintien de la
cohésion sociale mais j'attire votre
attention sur les efforts très
substantielles qui sont faits pour
justement donné à la branche familiale
et à la politique familiale les moyens
non seulement de perdurer dans dans ce
qui peut faire la force de la politique
familiale mais aussi d'avoir des
investissements d'avenir qui témoigne
bien de cette confiance que l'on peut
mettre dans la jeunesse
merci même donné quelques éléments de
réponses aux questions de cieux là bas
c'est madame premièrement concernant la
cns as les relais réserve saute
aujourd'hui de 220 230 millions d'euros
vous savez que la différence avec les
440 est en partie expliquer parce que
les réserves de la cns 1 ont servi au
fonds d'urgence en direction
des départements vous vous en servez
vous en souvenez
et
tu es bien d'accord et donc dans les 220
qui reste déjà d'ailleurs une partie est
déjà gager je vous ai indiqué tout à
l'heure que pour 70 millions les
réserves de la cia nsa inde et nous
aider à contribuer à
soutenir cet ondam à 3%
en ce qui concerne j'en parle maintenant
de la sous consommation
ça a été une de mes l'ambition d'essayer
qu'elle soit réduite au maximum ce qui
n'entend pas consommer tombant dans les
réserves de la et cns 1 en ce qui me
concerne et le le la sous consommation
étaient en 2011 de 246 millions d'euros
nous l'avons réduite à 189 l'année
derrière et elle est estimé à 130
millions d'euros pour cette année 2 est
due en particulier à un retard
d'installation de place
la question ensuite de la casa je crois
que on peut se dire entre nous que
chacun ici on aurait souhaité que la loi
août 2000 soit la plus précoce la
possible la décision n'avait pas été
prise jusqu'à l' annonce du premier
ministre qu'il s'agisse d'une loi
d'orientation et de programmation et
ceci nous impose un délai supplémentaire
puisque vous le savez ce type de loi
doit être présenté devant le conseil
économique et social donc l'agenda est
le suivant nous allons vous perdez le
mois de novembre à la concertation
je dirais officielle en conseil comme en
cent d'ailleurs par les départements
cette ce projet de loi ensuite nous
devrons discuter
concerter avec les partenaires sociaux
et le secteur tout cela dans un minimum
de temps justement pour ne pas trop
retarder le processus et parce que des
discussions bien sûr déjà eu lieu
ensuite il y aura un mois à prévoir pour
le conseil d'état deux mois pour le
saison est donc un passage en conseil
des ministres est imaginable je dis bien
ce n'est n'y a pas de date fixée ce
poids début avril soit
à la fin du mois de mars et
voilà le plus gros bas la loi pour ma
part je plaide pour que la discussion la
présentation devant le parlement en soit
entamée avant l'été parce qu'il y aura
après la collusion avec le prochain
plfss
mais de toute manière le premier
ministre nous a indiqué que les mesures
de la loi ne prendrait effet prendre
effet au 1er janvier 2015 donc pendant
cette période où vous savez des
ambitions notre gouvernement de
redressement des comptes publics de
retour progressif à l'équilibré cette
case à
2014 ira comme la précédente abonder le
fonds de solidarité vieillesse
deuxième
élément que vous avez demandé je vous ai
donc donné le détail de l'agenda en
effet la loi autonomie sera comportera
comme on l'a dit souvent même dans cette
enceinte trois volets prévention
adaptation de la société je préfère dire
ou des gis la longévité ou
vieillissement mais ce
pour favoriser un décor un vocabulaire
toujours positif et troisièmement à
l'accompagnement de la perte d'autonomie
avec un fil rouge qui sera la priorité
au domicile et donc comme l'a indiqué
dès janvier dernier le président de la
république ce n'est pas pour nous une
surprise il avait indiqué que la loi
montrait en charge par paliers
successifs et alors nous n'avions pas si
ce serait deux paliers ou trois paliers
ce sera donc deux paliers avec un
nouveau temps législatif qui sera soit
une nouvelle loi soit des dispositions
législatives dans un nouveau pv fait
sage crois qu'à cette heure ce n'est pas
tranché et qui comportera brasse ce qui
concerne les établissements
pour ma part je pense j'espère surtout
que nous pourrons déjà prendre quelques
mesures en faveur des établissements
d la poule un premier temps de la loi
qui pourrait être des mesures
de régulation qui aurais tu un bénéfice
sur le pouvoir d'achat des familles donc
mais en tout cas la majeure partie là
tout majeure partie de du deuxième temps
législatif sera en direction des
établissements madame tout raide l'a dit
avec la vérité que nous devons aux
parlementaires il est bien évident que
dans un monde idéal nous aurions préféré
faire la loi en un seul temps mais que
la contrainte budgétaire ne nous y
autorise pas je dois cependant fait
remarquer que moins de 18 mois après que
nous sommes arrivés aux affaires cette
loi est posée
son agenda est fixé et au regard de la
tante qu'on a eu cette loi on peut
considérer que c'est une grande ambition
car nous avons aujourd'hui moins
d'argent et plus d'âge et donc
c'est sa marque que notre gouvernement a
aussi dans ses priorités
le champ de l'âge
est ce qu'il y à des questions alors
l'aide à domicile monsieur la base et
vous savez mieux que personne que les
départements sont à la main d'oeuvre
pour une grande part nous avons mis en
place grâce à vous tous sur 20 vous tous
présidents de conseils généraux un
copilotage
cependant totalité des secteurs mais
quand même quelques-uns qu'elle que ça
partenaire particulier de la politique
de l'âge et donc co pilotage a été mis
en place entre les départements et les
l'état
réunissant autour de la table toutes les
grandes fédérations les ccas et les
caisses de retraite pour refonder l'aide
à domicile et il n'est pas certain que
cette même pas probable que l'aide à
domicile en tant que tel soit incluse
dans le champ de la loi du fait du chef
de file à tout à fait clair des
départements cependant ce qui sera dans
la première partie de la loi c'est la
réforme de l'apa à domicile et qui
dirait forme guy dans le cas
amélioration de l'apa domicile de même
seront dans ce premier volet ce qui
concerne encore le domicile c'est à dire
le chapitre des aidants l'accès aux
aides techniques et bien sûr le premier
chapitre celui de la prévention donc
voilà ce que nous pouvons dire
aujourd'hui la concertation s'ouvre
incessamment sous peu et j'espère que
douteraient je suis sûr que nous
travaillerons de manière aussi positive
que rapide pour que pour ne pas retarder
ce calendrier
merci mesdames les mini salon j'ai déjà
deux inscrits je vois de ma nouvelle
donc j'ai monsieur milon monsieur
carteron le sugen euros alors bon alors
déjà
j'ai dit monsieur millions
merci madame la présidente tout d'abord
une observation générale
nous sommes en train en commission après
en séance des amines et une loi qui
aurait dû être qu'ils auraient dû être
audacieuse qui ne l'est pas mais qui
existe c'est la loi sur les retraites
monsieur le rapporteur général va devoir
nous faire son rapport sur le plfss le 9
novembre
avec l'examen des amendements du
rapporteur le même jour nous nous aurons
la possibilité de déposer nos
amendements avant le 8 à 11 heures ce
qui nous laisse que 36 heures pour
regarder le texte du rapporteur et puis
faire nos amendements et un début de
séance le 12 novembre avec entre 2 le
week-end du 11 novembre qui oblige quand
même les les élus que nous sommes à être
dans nos territoires ne serait ce que
parce qu'ils ont les yeux je trouve que
ces conditions de travail ne respecte
pas le travail des sénateurs et je tiens
ici à le dénoncer parce que ça n'est pas
si évident de
revoir tous ces problèmes qui nous sont
exposés et j'imagine
l'attitude de l'opposition si nous
avions été nous la majorité à vous
imposer ce genre de rythme aujourd'hui
cela dit
madame la présidente juste peut-être
pour vous dire que ce sont des
délais constitutionnels qui nous sont
imposés du fait de fait le plfss arrive
ici après l'assemblée nationale
de fait ce sont des délais
constitutionnels qui nous est imposée et
qui sont difficiles à tenir je vous
l'accord mais tout ça a été débattue en
conférence des présidents et a trouvé
accord au sein de la conférence des
présidents à la juste exactement le
genre de réponse que je vous aurais
donné si vous aviez été à ma place mais
bon sa fille qui veut pas dire qu'on
peut pas qu'on n'a pas le droit d'être
mécontents de la façon dont ça se passe
y compris qu'on y compris contre la
conférence des présidents pour le reste
madame la ministre vous avez parlé des
déficits alors j'étais un petit peu au
départ ailleurs vous avez bien dit 21
milliards pour 2012
2011 16 pour 2012
et 12 10 et 16 2013 seize 2013
donc 16 2013 et donc combien pour 2012
c'est moi
18 16 2013 si vous n'avez pas dit c'est
que un déficit c'est toujours la
différence ça chez moi à la maison entre
les recettes et les dépenses
et que donc vous avez augmenté les
recettes de quatre et demi quatre
milliards et demi de cotisations et
d'impôts nouveaux dans le cadre du plfss
2013 ça vous n'avez vous avez vous bien
me dire alors il est peut-être utile que
nous leur disions ici et le rapporteur
général a fait une allusion qui est
intéressante et qui d'ailleurs je vais
faire également on constate quand même
qu'à une légère diminution de la
consommation médicale leur légère au
niveau d'un médecine de ville mais assez
importante au niveau d'un médecine
hospitalière puisque si l'on dame était
à 2,7 pour 2013 il semblerait qu'on soit
un petit peu au-dessus de 1%
d'augmentation de la consommation en
2013 par rapport à 2012 d'après ce que
me disent les hôpitaux dans le cadre de
la fédération donc peut-être stagnation
ou légère augmentation de la
consommation donc de réponse est très
nette augmentation des recettes par des
impôts nouveaux vous avez mis en place
sans compter que pour 2014 il va y avoir
à nouveau une augmentation des
cotisations vieillesse de nouvelles
cotisations pour le rsi diminution du
quotient familial de nouvelle taxe sur
l'industrie du médicament ce qui me
semble donc encore une fois peser
davantage sur
l'ensemble de ce que vous appelez la
minorité des gens qui payent des impôts
c'est à dire les classes moyennes qui
commence en avoir un peu ras-le-bol de
toutes ces augmentations d'impôts je
conçois que ce n'est pas si évident de
trouver le moyen de faire un équilibre
sans trouver des recettes nouvelles mais
en attendant les classes moyennes ont un
peu ras-le-bol de cette situation je ne
vais pas revenir sur ce qu'a dit madame
la rapporteur sur l'a21 branche famille
juste pour dire quand même que son
observation est celle qui a été faite
par valérie rabault à l'assemblée
nationale et que hélas rapporteur du
sénat et la rapporte à l'assemblée
nationale ne sont pas du même parti
politique dont il ya un certain accord
entre certains rapporteur sur le sujet
la branche famille en fait vous nous
dites clairement qu'avant il y avait des
variables d'ajustement qui étaient mises
en place par les ministres et vous vous
augmentez la cotisations retraites
patronales de 1,2 milliard et en
compensation vous diminuez la la la
cotisation patronale de la famille de
1,2 milliard si c'est pas une variable
d'ajustement je sais pas ce que c'est
mais en attendant nous on le faisait et
vous ne dénonce y est vous êtes en train
de le faire on ne votera pas les avants
demande de l'âme de la
rapporteur sur le sujet mais je tenais
quand même à vous dire que vous faites
la même chose alors ne critiquez pas
quand vous faites la même chose au moins
dit que vous faites comme nous dans
certaines conditions j'ai deux questions
à vous poser madame ministre c'est une
sur la caisse des mines laquelle spin
hier
dans dans la
l'article 25 du projet de loi vous dit
dans l'article 25 cette caste des mines
est évidemment en grosses difficultés
financières et que l'acoss fera des
avances de trésorerie pour cette caisse
à hauteur de 250 millions pour une promo
pour une période de quatre ans à partir
de 2013 en affirmant dans le rapport que
cette intervention avance de trésorerie
de l'acoss intervient en complément des
avances et prêts obtenus auprès de la
caisse de dépôt il semblerait certains
me disent qu'il n'y a pas d' avance de
la caisse de dépôt j'aimerais vous me
confirmer si vraiment il ya avance ou
intervention de la caisse de dépôt en
plus des 250 millions de l'acoss sur le
sujet et puis il ya des bruits qui
disent aussi que il devrait y avoir une
généralisation des complémentaires santé
dans le cadre du plfss est ce que ce
sera le cas
merci monsieur pierre daran
oui merci d'abord pour me réjouir dans
un premier temps de l'annonce qui était
faite par madame la ministre de launay
du plan de ses vrais perte d'autonomie
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un plan
qui est attendu attendu pas que depuis
le changement de mandature mais bien
depuis quelques quelques années
et je suis assez satisfait des réponses
formulées notamment sur la taxe casa
parce que c'est vrai que beaucoup
d'acteurs en tout cas certain nombre
d'acteurs du secteur avait considéré que
la réaffectation si je puis dire était
plutôt une sorte de captation donc la
réponse que vous nous faites me convient
tout cas je mens je m'en félicite et par
contre
j'aurai une question sur le financement
futur de cette réforme du fait de ce
de cette réaffectation
ensuite j'aurai une question sur aux
deux questions sur un sujet qui devient
un peu de marotte c'est la santé des
étudiants avec ma collègue catherine
procaccia nous avons commis il ya
quelques mois un rapport sur la
protection sociale et la santé des
étudiants j'ai simplement prendre un ou
deux exemples
concernant dans votre dans le plan qui
est annoncée il ya quelques et quelques
temps maintenant que semaine sur la
stratégie nationale de santé vous avez
annoncé la généralisation du tiers
payant d'ici 2017 pour faciliter l'accès
aux soins aux soins de ville ce qui est
une excellente une excellente mesure
envisagée vous dès 2014 de faire
bénéficier les étudiants de cette
opportunité je rappellerai que en 2012
il avait été envisagé une
expérimentation me semble-t-il dans
quelques villes universitaires je pense
que c'était nombre de trois mais que ça
avait dû être pour retoquer comme on dit
par le conseil constitutionnel donc il y
aura t-il il reste quelque chose dans ce
sens et à défaut est il envisageable
comme le préconise et en 2009 un rapport
de l'igas qui est qui portait sur la
prévention des grossesses non désirées
de mettre en place un tiers payant pour
la contrat c'est la contraception par
exemple par exemple
ensuite envisagez-vous d'aménager les
critères d'accès à la csc la cmu-c ça ce
sont deux demandes fortes sur
qui émane des des mutuelles étudiantes
et puis
rappelez simplement que la
multiplication des taxes sur les
complémentaires santé les différents
transferts de charges qui datent pas
d'aujourd'hui qui date d'un de la
mandature précédente
vers les organismes complémentaires pèse
lourdement sur les étudiants puisque à
titre d'exemple sur 100 euros de
cotisation que verse un étudiant mais on
a déjà 13 qui partent en taxes et puis
un souhait à émettre c'est que dans la
stratégie nationale de santé il y ait un
volet jeunesse ou étudiants en tout cas
qui prennent en compte un certain nombre
de propositions de préconisations que
nous avions formulées en notre notre
temps
merci madame procas ya justement
des questions très rapide alors je pense
alain que tu l'a évoqué en parlant des
complémentaires mais nous avons lu dans
la presse madame la ministre que vous
comptiez
réintroduire les dispositions qui ont
été annulés par le conseil
constitutionnel sur l'année est ce que
c'est vrai ou pas
deuxième question
j'ai lu la dernière aussi nous avions
réussi à repousser je crois par le
conseil constitutionnel le fait que vous
êtes inquiet aux réserves enfin vous
attaquer ou la msa s'attaque aux
réserves du ghana du gamme ex et cette
année je voulais j'ai vu que dans votre
texte ben vous comptiez reprendre la
gestion
réattribuer la gestion de ces assurances
maladie pour les affecter à la msa
j'aimerais savoir qu'est-ce qui vous
guide ya quand même un simple de
personnes et pas mal d organismes qui
travaillent
là dessus est effectivement
avoir quelques précisions une question
qui est purement d'actualité qui ne
relève peut-être pas du plfss met sur la
gestion des urgences par rapport à la
maladie à l'hospitalisation est ce que
vous pensez pouvoir faire quelque chose
pour que cette grève des urgentistes qui
s'explique effectivement concrètement en
tout cas en région parisienne quand on
cherche à avoir une place est ce que le
ministre peut faire quelque chose et
peut accentuer les choses là dessus puis
bon sécurité sociale étudiante
effectivement renan a dit un certain
nombre d'éléments il y en avait quand
même beaucoup d'autres qui concernaient
la gestion
que j'ai présentées en tout cas dans le
texte sur l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche qui émane est directement de
nos auditions et j'ai eu la surprise
non pas d'avoir la réponse de la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
mais de savoir en offre que bell et
mutuelles étudiantes étaient opposés
alors que c'était des propositions
qu'elle nous avait fait est qu'ils ont
dans notre rapport particulier sur des
économies de gestion sur la datte
d'affiliation au 1er septembre et non
pas au 1er octobre après entendre dire
qu'elles y sont opposés c'est surprenant
mais avec ronan on se coordonnera ouais
voilà
merci dernier inscrit à rené paul savary
merci moi je partage et les propos de
georges labazée par rapport à son
intervention sur sur la cnl ça comprenez
que c'est quand même difficile
d'entendre qu'il ya encore 440 millions
d'euros de réserves quand ce fonds qui
doit être au titre de l'autonomie et
notamment
220 on sait bien qu'ils d'accord
mais on sait bien sûr de 2013 n'ont
ramené à 220 voilà est par ailleurs il
ya de la sous consommation c'est ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure il ya déjà une
consommation au type de 2013 à hauteur
de 130 millions d'euros le comprenez je
continue merci mon propos alors
d'interprétation sur les chiffres pour
lire ce décès quand même difficile
d'entendre ça quand on sait que ce fonds
est fait quand même poids la solidarité
de l'autonomie notamment distribué par
les départements qui sont dans des
situations particulièrement difficiles
puisque la panne n'est pas compensé la
moindre idée des compensations de la
passer 30% et l autonomie par rapport au
handicap c'est la prestation notamment
de compensation du handicap qui n est
bien sûr là aussi insuffisamment
compensées et le fonctionnement des
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées qui ne fonctionne pas avec
la seule subvention de la scène est ça
qui n'est plus le principal contributeur
au niveau des des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées puissent maintenant ce sont
les subventions des départements qui
permettent à ces maisons de fonctionner
elle verse plus d'argent que la scène et
ça pour le fonctionnement donc là dessus
il ya quelque part une déviation une
déviance ou à détournement des fonds
consacrés à la solidarité pour
l'autonomie qui continue 1 qui continue
qui s'accentue d'année en année alors
qu'il y avait une piste véritablement
pour permettre au département de mieux
assurer leur mission dans ce domaine là
nous les taux directeurs en tout cas moi
dans mon département le taux directeurs
proposé aux
structures d'hébergement va être cette
année encore de 0,5 pour cent vous voyez
les difficultés que ça peut faire dans
d'andorre dans les différentes
structures parce que on est contraint
d'avoir des ddd mesure terriblement
rigoureuse compte tenu de cette absence
de compensation donc j'appuyais les
propos de mon collègue georges labazée
sur ce j'avais une autre question plus
précise
avez-vous abonder le fonds national de
la petite enfance que aussi un sujet de
litige entre l'état et les départements
concernant la prise en charge notamment
dans le cadre des mineurs étrangers
isolés où il a été envisagé lors des
groupes de travail
cet appel pour financer en partie ce qui
revient là encore à la charge des
départements et qui correspond plus à
une politique nationale de l'immigration
ou de la justice qui a une politique de
l'enfance
merci monsieur ça varie donc mesdames
ministre je vous laisse
dans vos réponses qui veut démarrer
bien plusieurs plusieurs questions
bon goûter on aura le débat en séance
sur le financement de la sécurité
sociale
je n'ai pas dit qu'il y avait pas eu de
recettes complémentaires j'ai même dit
que c'est dès notre arrivée aux
responsabilités que nous avions pris des
mesures qui avaient permis le reggae
libre âge l'année prochaine par rapport
à l'évolution tendancielle des dépenses
nous réalisons 8 milliards de baisse du
déficit 4 par le biais de prélèvements
supplémentaires et quatre par le biais
d'économies
nous avons indiqué toujours qu'
il n'y aurait pas de prélèvement
[Musique]
pesant sur les assurés en termes de
santé
les prélèvements réalisés sont
parfaitement identifiés j'y reviens pas
c'est des cotisations vieillesse
notamment ils sont parfaitement
identifiés il n'empêche que l'année
dernière nous avons fait 2 milliard et
demi d'économies sur l'assurance maladie
que l'année prochaine en fin d'année
donc l'année actuelle nous avons fait 2
milliard et demi d'économies plus 500
millions qui n'était pas prévu mais qui
sont donc réalisés et nous ferons
l'année prochaine
de l'ordre de deux milliards et demi à
d'économies
supplémentaires donc les échos en
matière d'assurance maladie
les soldes évidemment que j'ai données
de la sécurité sociale tout à l'heure ne
portait pas uniquement sur l'assurance
maladie mais sans la sécurité sociale et
le fonds de solidarité vieillesse pris
globalement
mais on aura le débat sur la manière de
financer après tout
je crois que je suis assez prête à
confronter les bilans pour ce qui est
de la caisse des mines
je vous confirme que cette caisse la can
à une convention avec la caisse des
dépôts
donc ce que nous faisons là c'est que
dans le cadre des mesures que nous
allons être amenés à prendre pour le
régime minier nous prévoyons
qu'ils ont une sécurisation financière
qui permet de répondre sur les quatre
années qui viennent
à la situation que peut rencontrer ce ce
régime
il n'y a pas de mesure de généralisation
des complémentaires santé au sens strict
il y a des étapes
ajoutée ou des étapes franchies
la première étape je veux le rappeler
c'est le relèvement du seuil de la cmu
et de l'aide à la complémentaire santé
qui est entrée en vigueur le 1er juillet
qui va être financé donc quand même à
part entière à partir de l'année
prochaine
pour un semestre cette année qui permet
à 750 mille personnes de plus de
bénéficier d'une prise en charge
soit gratuite soit avec l'aide pour la
complémentaire santé je veux rappeler
parce qu on ne l ignore trop souvent que
pour quelqu'un qui a 60 ans et plus
l'aide à la complémentaire santé c'est
500 euros par an 500 euros ça n'est
quand même pas négligeable et je veux
ramener ça ou rapporter ça au débat que
nous avons avoir tout à l'heure sur la
question des
retraités par ailleurs nous premier
effectivement des mesures et là je
réponds un ami long mais je commence à
répondre à ronan kerdraon à l'article 45
enfin tel qu'il est pour le moment de la
loi qui concerne les jeunes et puis les
mesures à l'article sais plus combien
sur les critères aussi
45 aussi sur les critères des tarifs
responsable et solidaire donc nous avons
l'étape de la nuit je répondrai à madame
profession nous avons eu l'étape de
l'ami nous avons eu l'étape cmu
acs 750 mille bénéficiaires de plus et
nous avons dans le plfss un double
mécanisme avec le renforcement des
critères qu'on les contrats responsables
et solidaires ce qui doit aussi nous
permettre d'améliorer la qualité des
contrats parce que l'objectif d'une
couverture complémentaire de santé c'est
évidemment un objectif quantitatif de
généralisation c'est aussi un objectif
qualitatif de meilleure prise en charge
et nous prenons des mesures en direction
des jeunes avec un accès facilité à la
cmu en particulier pour les étudiants
qui sont dans des situations d'isolement
ou de rupture familiale et qui
aujourd'hui doit faire des démarches
absolument
pas très compliqué pour démontrer qu'ils
n'ont pas laide ou le soutien de leur
famille donc aujourd'hui enfin à partir
du plfss tout cela va changer puisque
nous allons faciliter
cela
oui il y aura évidemment des mesures en
direct les jeunes dans le cadre de la
stratégie nationale de santé je n'ai dit
ce sera un des axes prioritaires j'ai
que la concertation allait
s'engager pour définir les priorités de
santé publique ne que nous mettions en
avant mais que d'ores et déjà il y en
avait cinq qui devrait de toute façon
figurer parmi ces 5 il y à celle de la
jeunesse oui il y à une mesure sur le
tiers payant
concernant l'accès
concernant les jeunes filles les jeunes
femmes mineures de 15 à 17 ans et 364
jours donc peuvent depuis l'année
dernière bénéficier de la gratuité
de la contraception
cette année nous introduisons une mesure
qui consiste à leur permettre d'accéder
au tiers payant pour la consultation est
pour les actes liés à la consultation
par exemple des actes de biologie donc
c'est une mesure qui me semble aller
dans le sens de
mais mais mais
oui mais mais pour pour c'est vrai mais
pour ce qui est des étudiantes dans le
cadre de centres de santé les centres de
santé étudiants offre déjà la
possibilité du tiers payant à l'évidence
nous sommes dans une démarche de
généralisation nous sommes dans une
démarche de généralisation du tiers
payant et de toute façon la volonté
c'est que l'année prochaine le tiers
payant soit offert enfin offert
accessible aux bénéficiaires de l'aide à
la complémentaire santé donc il y as
parmi eux une partie de la population
étudiante qui sera directement
concernés pour ce qui est de la nuit
quel est le sujet le conseil
constitutionnel a annulé une disposition
qui prévoyait la clause désignation quel
était l'intérêt de la cause de
désignation c'était de permettre un
meilleur tarif proposé des
complémentaires santé grâce à la
mutualisation des contrats parce qu'on
sait bien que plus les contrats sont
segmentés plus ils sont chers plus vous
avez une base de mutualisation large
plus vous pouvez vous permettre de faire
des contrats à moindre coût puisque vous
compensez au fond les risques que vous
pouvez en courir sur une partie de la
population par de moindres risques sur
une autre population si vous faites un
contrat à cibler personnes âgées il est
évident que la probabilité que votre
adhérents n'aillent pas voir un médecin
dans l'année est quand même assez faible
si vous compensez personnage et par
population plus jeune vous équilibrez
donc vous permettez à une personne âgée
d'avoir un contrat à moindre coût si
donc si on est dans le secteur du
travail là on parlera pas personnage est
encore qu'à 55 ans on est encore dans le
monde du travail on n'est pas une
personne âgée mais je veux dire qu'on a
plus
oui mais en termes de risques santé oms
va plus voir son médecin que le salarié
de 35 ans est par ailleurs surtout la
mutualisation elle porte pas uniquement
sur l'âge elle porte sur
les pathologies que vous avez pu
rencontrer aller voir un assureur quand
vous avez eu un cancer et vous allez
voir les tarifs qui vous fait tant dis
que si vous avez un enfant qui est
réalisé pour la branche ou pour
l'entreprise on fera pas la différence
entre celui qui a eu un cancer est un
autre tout le monde paiera la même chose
simplement évidemment
non mais ça c'est pas dans le cadre de
l'ani
ça
non mais sur la nuit donc jeudi
l'objectif
l'objectif c'est de permettre la
mutualisation
donc nous sommes en train de voir quels
dispositifs nous pouvons mettre en place
qui permettent de favoriser la
mutualisation des contrats et c'est ça
l'enjeu des discussions que nous avons
en ce moment pour ce qui est de la msa
pour ce qu'elle est mais ça y est du
gamme ex concrètement
le gamme ex les dispositions de l'année
dernière n'ont pas été maintenus
pour des raisons de mauvaise rédaction
le gamin il gère des prestations maladie
en concurrence avec la bsm et ça et au
titre de la gestion il percevait où il
perçoit une fraction des cotisations
agricole pour payer les frais de gestion
il se trouve que ce montant perçu et
supérieurs aux coûts de gestion il n'est
donc pas anormal que la différence
reviennent à la msa pour ce qui est des
urgences ça n'est pas dans le cadre du
plfss
mais le mouvement qui a lieu
actuellement est un mouvement qui vise
de la part des services d'urgence et
d'urgentistes a demandé à ce que la
gestion des directions des hôpitaux
assument la responsabilité
de la gestion des de la réaffectation
des malades qui sortent des urgences
mais qui doivent rester hospitalisé
aujourd'hui les urgentistes ont le
sentiment d'être laissés à eux-mêmes et
de passer beaucoup de temps et de perdre
beaucoup d'énergie à trouver des lits
d'aval pour reprendre la formule pour
leurs patients j'ai travaillé avec les
urgentistes au cours des mois derniers
j'ai lancé un programme de gestionnaires
de lits
160 hôpitaux sont d'ores et déjà engagés
dans la mise en place d'un dispositif de
gestion des lits d'aval au niveau de
l'hôpital est pas au niveau du service
d'urgence c'est ça qui est absolument
fondamentale et les urgentistes ont
insisté là-dessus et c'est la première
fois qu'un plan gouvernemental s'inscrit
dans cette démarche j'ai reçu tous les
urgentistes il ya quelques jours et
était présent les directeurs d'hôpitaux
les présidents de cme c'est que c'est la
première fois qu'on a un engagement des
hôpitaux et pas simplement un plan
urgent centrée sur les urgences il par
ailleurs demandé aux directions
d'hôpital sans attendre la mise en place
de ces systèmes de gestion d'aval de
lits d'aval de mettre en place des
systèmes d'organisation qui permettent
de soulager les
urgentistes j'ai indiqué par ailleurs
que là où ce serait nécessaire
des moyens humains seraient mis en place
il n'y en a pas besoin partout où des
restructurations même immobilière enfin
des aménagements de locaux il n'y en a
pas besoin partout et nous avons
d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà pris des
mesures dans certains établissements qui
ont permis de rétablir la situation
je pense avoir répondu aux questions qui
s'adressait à moi en tout cas
très bien madame jeu madame personnes il
y avait une question concernant les
mineurs isolés je rappelle que le fonds
auxquels vous faites référence à a été
créé en 2007 et que abandonné la cnaf
avait été sollicité pour l'abonder
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que en fin
d'année dernière le financement du fonds
a été à nouveau amendé le par des
ressources qui ont été et lors d'une
discussion qui a eu lieu entre l'état et
précisément
l'adf et que des solutions de
financement de ce fonds avait été trouvé
sans avoir à passer par le plfss
donc je crois que voilà la réponse que
je peux vous apporter sur ce qui
concerne la gestion entre autres des
mineurs isolés et du fonds auxquels vous
faisiez référence merci madame donné
peut-être deux courtes réponses je crois
que c'est madame pro cassia qu'il use a
interrogé sur le financement de la du
deuxième temps de la loi de financement
futur de la loi le nom c'est
par peur de pardonnez moi le premier
temps de la loi dans la période actuelle
sera
engagée dans le montant de la casa
et le deuxième temps je ne surprendrai
pas en disant que rien n'était arbitré
le concernant
deuxième aspect monsieur savary là je
suis sûr que c'est bien lui nous a dit
bon il disons qu'il a un petit peu râlé
en dix ans mais nous voyons des réserves
de la cns 1 alors que les conseils
généraux n'en profite pas autant que
qu'il le voudrait je rappelle quand même
que nous avons là je dis non mais la
caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie à abonder les 170 millions
du fonds d'urgence alors que et sa 9e
départ compensé la seule pch et seul
appât donc on à financer le rsa avec
avec cette caisse donc les conseils
généraux n'ont pas été oubliés et j'ai
trouvé que ce jour là le conseil de la
cd ça avait été
tout à fait
responsable à votre égard et solidaire
voilà en fait ils n'ont pas râler euh
voilà non des monsieurs savary chevelu
quoi bon à 5 millions d'euros bon mais
donc je soulignais ce point mais comme
vous vous l'avons exprimé les recettes
de l'aller par dont les réserves de sign
et ça que tout le monde regarde comme
vous même avec beaucoup d'attention et
même plus que de la tension
sont pour la plupart celles qui sont
actuellement déjà gager comme je les
exprimer et
nous essaierons deux à la fois de moins
sous consommer encore cette année et
d'en préserver l' usage au maximum pour
les personnes vulnérables auxquelles
sont destinés
très bien merci mesdames les ministres
je crois que nous avons fait le tour de
l'ensemble des questions et je voudrais
vous remercier pour le temps que vous
avez passé à nos côtés pour répondre à
l'ensemble de nos questions marisol peut
être marisol touraine pardon peut-être
un peu plus puisque puisqu'elle est là
depuis effectivement 16h30 et on parle
des retraites et du père fss donc merci
pour votre disponibilité à répondre à
l'ensemble des questions des sénatrices
et sénateurs et comme vous avez pu le
remarquer il y en a un certain nombre et
donc les débats qui s'annoncent vont
sans doute être riche en échanges
pendant la séance publique merci
voilà pour cette double audition d'abord
sur la réforme des retraites puis sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour ce qui est de la
réforme des retraites qui a été adopté
d'ailleurs maradi de justesse par
l'assemblée nationale elle doit arriver
en séance publique au sénat à la fin du
mois le 28 octobre pour ce qui est du
plfss 2014 il sera examiné en séance
publique le 12 novembre vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire à 19h24 orsenna avec
delphine girard très bonne journée sur
la chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]